- We are trying to start off 2021
with strength and positivity.
So all week I've been
talking about some authors
I turn to when I need an emotional boost,
some of the best inspirational
minds on the planet.
People including Glennon
Doyle, DeVon Franklin
and Brene Brown.
Another one is the
great Dr. Deepak Chopra.
He says, "Victims always
feel alone and helpless.
Freedom from victimhood is creativity."
"I could not agree more",
says the creative person
sitting in front of you.
I think we can all relate
to feeling victimized by 2020, right?
(applause)
Yeah, it doesn't matter who
you are, it kind of sucked.
But those, exactly, I got a amen!
Well, those words completely ring true
for Isa who's joining us today.
2020 was really tough on you, right, Isa?
- Yes, it was pretty tough.
It started off super hopeful,
but as the pandemic began
I lost three jobs.
I lost all my income
and just a couple of weeks ago,
one of my good friends,
lifelong friends passed away.
I had to cancel my 30th
birthday trip to Belize
and I am still living at home with my mom.
So, to say that I feel
helpless is an understatement.
And to feel like 2020
has diminished my hopes.
So it just really sucks.
- Yeah, you know what?
Simply put, yep.
But why does Deepak's
quote mean so much to you?
Why does it hit home with you?
- Because I'm feeling like a victim
and we are all victims to this year.
The circumstances have
forced that title on us.
And so for his quote,
I'm reminded that I have to rise
above the circumstances
that I can't control.
And I feel like we all need to rise
above those circumstances
that we have no control over,
especially for 2021.
- Yeah, and for people
that are control freaks,
that is hard.
But good news though, we have
Deepak joining us this hour
and not only is he going to
share his advice for Isa,
he's also got suggestions
for how all of us
can feel more empowered
to take on the world.
'Cause it has felt really big lately.
So it's nice to feel like
you got a grasp on something.
So Dr. Chopra, you teamed up
with Oprah to help people cope
with the stress we've
all faced lately, right?
- Yes, so Oprah and I have
been teaching meditation online
and we reached about 10 million people
in the last few years.
And right now we are
also engaging with people
on a 21 day meditation experience
called "Creating Peace
from the Inside Out",
which is very important right now
in times of turbulence and
so much ideological conflict.
- That's great.
Well, we already talked to Isa
about how she can start 2021 right.
But we also have some more people
in the audience who could use
a little guidance as well.
So let's start with Diamond.
What's going on with you girl?
- Yes, well, Kelly, I'll be honest.
I've always been a super confident woman.
Like, I'm the life of the party.
When I step into a room,
I am bringing so much positive energy.
I'm a mom, I have my own
business doing social
media management, I host events.
And so with this year and
everything that's going on,
it literally stopped, as we all know,
and it totally knocked me off
my square, everything paused.
And I was really left, feeling lost
and angry and just really
not knowing what to do.
I lost a lot of connections
with people and I really thrive
off that human connection.
Just trying to figure out
how to pivot my business
in this time where it's
like so many events
and getting out there.
So I need to figure out how
do I get that confidence back?
Find that confident,
strong woman that I know
deep down inside that I am.
So I can really continue to inspire
my children, my daughters.
And so I'm just trying to figure out
where do I even begin with a year
being so crazy and draining?
- Well, maybe with that meditation thing
he was just talking about,
but let's talk to Dr. Chopra.
- One thing you can do instantly
anytime you're stressed is use
what I call the stop formula.
S-T-O-P.
S stands for stop, T stands
for take three deep breaths
and smile from your head
to your toes, everywhere.
O, observe your breath
and your body sensations.
And then P, proceed with
awareness, compassion, and joy.
But what you're also doing,
which is very effective,
is you're expressing your vulnerability.
And that is very important.
It's a sign of strength.
When we express our
vulnerabilities to each other,
we are stronger.
So we ask for help and we give help.
Social scientists these
days talk about something
called the happiness formula,
which is basically,
are you seeing problems
or are you seeing opportunities?
What are the conditions of your living?
And do you have meaning and purpose?
And can you make other people happy?
The fastest way to
increase your self-esteem
and be happy is to make
somebody else happy.
- That's my favorite
thing that I've kind of
heard people say in this
time, 'cause doing this show
it's been absolutely a
blessing for me personally
because you hear people
say, you know what,
if you're having a hard time
why don't you help someone else?
Not only does it just
kind of take you away
from your own egocentric
moment that you're suffering
but you're focusing on
someone else, you help us
and that makes you feel good.
And it's so true.
Do you feel like that?
- Absolutely, I spent a
lot of my time doing that
to make myself feel
better when I can't just
make myself feel better.
I find that if you're able
to help someone bridge
that gap of trying to get to that spot,
whether it's just having a
conversation or being able
to help with this month's rent,
or it's something as small as just being
an ear to listen to.
- Yeah.
What do you think Nathan, does
any of that hit home for you?
- I mean, first of all, I love this.
Thank you very much for
everybody being here
because it's not normal to sit and wallow
in this kind of a stressful place.
There's always another side.
We always come out of
it on the other side.
So I know it's there,
but having the steps, having the guidance,
having the try this, it's very comforting.
- So Dr. Deepak, before we go,
you just started a new
AI project that you kind
of referenced and it sounds really cool.
So can you tell us about it?
'Cause you said it kind of,
it's an artificial intelligence
but it also sets you up with other humans.
Is that what you were saying?
That kind of connect with people?
How does it work?
- I have an AI bot, which
is on neveralone.love,
which can immediately assess
whether you're at risk
for depression and can
befriend you and guide you
and even connect you to
counselors and it's all free.
- Oh my gosh, that's amazing!
It's all free?
- Yes.
So check out, neveralone.love
and look for Piwi,
she's the AI bot that can
become your best friend
if you want.
- Oh my God, that's really cool.
Thank you so much for taking
the time everybody today.